so right over here i have the graph of
the function y is equal to 15 over x or
at least i see the part of it for
positive values of x and what i'm
curious about in this video is i want to
find the area not between this curve and
the positive x-axis i want to find the
area up between the curve and the y-axis
bounded not by two x-values but bounded
by two y-values so with the bottom bound
of the horizontal line y is equal to e
and an upper bound with y is equal to e
to the third power
so pause this video and see if you can
work through it so one way to think
about it this is just like definite
integrals we've done where we're looking
between the curve and the x-axis but now
it looks like things are swapped around
we now care about the y-axis so let's
just rewrite our function here and let's
rewrite it in terms of x so if y is
equal to 15 over x that means if we
multiply both sides by x x y is equal to
15 and if we divide both sides by y we
get x is equal to 15 over y these right
over here are all going to be equivalent
now how does this right over here help
you
well think about
the area think about estimating the area
is a bunch of little rectangles here so
that's one rectangle and then another
rectangle right over there and then
another rectangle right over there so
what's the area of each of those
rectangles
so the width here that is going to be x
but we can express x as a function of y
so that's the width right over there and
we know that that's going to be 15
over y
and then what's the height going to be
well that's going to be a very small
change in y
the height is going to be d y
so the area of one of those little
rectangles right over there say the area
of that one right over there you could
view as
let me do it over here as 15 over y
d y
and then we want to sum all of these
little rectangles from y is equal to e
all the way to y is equal to e to the
third power so that's what our definite
integral does we go from y is equal to e
to y is equal to e to the third power
so all we did we're used to seeing
things like this where this would be 15
over x dx all we're doing here is this
is 15 over y d y
so let's evaluate this
so we take the anti-derivative of 15
over y and then evaluated these two
points so this is going to be equal to
anti-derivative of 1 over y
is going to be
the natural log of the absolute value of
y so it's 15
times the natural log of the absolute
value of y and then we're going to
evaluate that at our endpoints so we're
going to evaluate it at
e to the third
and
at e
so let's first evaluate it e to the
third so that's 15
times the natural log the absolute times
the natural natural log of the absolute
value of e to the third power
minus
times the natural log of the absolute
value of e
so what does this simplify to the
natural log of e to the third power what
power would have to raise e2 to get to e
to the third well that's just going to
be three
and then the natural log of e
what power do i have to raise e to to
get e well that's just 1. so this is 15
times 3 minus 15. so that is all going
to get us to
30.
and we are done 45 minus 15.